48 jours que le bras de fer dure depuis
le début de la grève aucune pièce de
moteur ne sort de la fonderie mbf qui
fournit notamment renault et peugeot
malgré les engagements pris par les deux
constructeurs français
l'inquiétude gagne les salariés depuis
que la direction de mbf a été évincé
force est de constater que psa plus ou
moins maintiendrait ses engagements
horreur mais renault c'est la
dégringolade je vais dire ça comme ça
puisque à partir de 2023 désengage
totalement de la fonderie alors qu'ils
ont des engagements jusqu'en 2026
hauteur de 15 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires par an de leur côté
les élus locaux se mobilisent pour
offrir des garanties et accompagner
salariés entreprises
plusieurs propositions de reprise ont
été transmises mais une seule jugé
fiable et pérenne par le tribunal de
commerce de dijon avec le maintien de
229 cdi au lieu de 280 sur le candidat
qui reste en liste je pense qu'il a
donné toutes les assurances possible
pour nous sécuriser et sécurisé
notamment l'intersyndicale pour la
viabilité de son projet donc on a
effectivement bon espoir d'arriver
les collectivités ont pris des
engagements et des engagements forts qui
doivent aussi aidé le tribunal à prendre
ces décisions
et maintenant on attend aussi beaucoup
des constructeurs pour qu'ils tiennent
leurs engagements
autre option la mise en liquidation de
l'entreprise
une solution qui plongerait la ville en
plein désarroi économique dans une
région déjà impacté par les
délocalisations
c'est une entreprise historique de la
ville on ne peut même pas imaginer que
nous perdions quasiment 300 emplois ce
qui veut dire une des familles
représentent 1000 personnes en
difficulté et qui roux qui auront
beaucoup de mal à retrouver de l'emploi
sur place c'est donc catastrophique à la
fois pour les villes de saint claude
pour l'entreprise à leurs familles
salariées bien entendu le 14 avril
dernier les salariés avaient écrit au
ministère de l'économie pour
l'interpeller sur la situation de la
fonderie sans réponse cinq d'entre eux
ont donc rejoint paris aujourd'hui ils
vont entamer une grève de la faim devant
bercy